How you feeling buddy?
You're gonna become a table tennis player
How do you feel about that?
We have to make sure it doesn't fly off
Probably you should not try this at home
I have a bad feeling that
something is gonna go wrong here
I think we just give it a go!
The beast is waking up
Look at that!
It flies!
At least that's positive
It looks so cool!
Yeah it works quite well
I'm getting the touch
Or I'm not sure is it the drone
that is getting the touch?
That was almost a Jackpot!
He seems to know what he's doing
Okay so based on the first interaction
with the drone
I think I'm gonna need these
He got his first shot on!
Look at his victory lap
Where did that go?
I'm just waiting for the Jackpot
Yeah it's gonna happen
What!?
He got it on!
I wasn't expecting that I can tell you
It broke the ball!
There's one piece
Look at that ball!
Sorry
Nice work!
You're supposed to serve
Towards me
High five!
Even though I have the controller
I feel like I'm not in control!
Are you okay?
He's alive!
He is okay
You blocked it!
This is how you do an around the net
That's how you do it!
Do you wanna also try?
Ah
Good!
There we have it!
We did it!
It wasn't a roller
It wasn't the fastest around the net
It was pretty safe around the net
Yeah, well done!
Only 32% of you guys watching me have subscribed the channel
Please subscribe now if you want to see me again!